House Democrats will begin their
impeachment argument in just a few hours
after a long opening session of the
Senate trial senators took more than 12
hours to debate the rules for the trial
with each party accusing the other of
acting in bad faith they finally
approved the Republican blueprint just
before 2 o'clock this morning Democrats
proposed 11 amendments to the schedule
laid out by Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell Republicans defeated all of
them a short time ago the president
attending the World Economic Forum in
Davos Switzerland slammed the
impeachment process it's a total hoax
it's a disgrace they talked about their
tremendous case and it's all done their
tremendous case they had no case it's
all a hoax
chip Reid covered the 1999 Clinton
impeachment trial and he just spent the
day and night on Capitol Hill chip what
do we expect today
well we're expecting another marathon
day opening arguments begin early this
afternoon and we're expecting a very
fierce debate over why the president
should and shouldn't be removed from
office
Republicans want this all over by the
State of the Union address in two weeks
Democrats say not so fast they will not
permit the American people to hear from
the witnesses and they lie and lie and
lie and lie
closing in on 1 a.m. house impeachment
manager Jerry Nadler blasted the
president's lawyers executive privilege
is a shield not a sword it cannot be
used to block a witness who is willing
to testify it's embarrassing
the president's counsels would talk
about this today the defense shot back
the only one who should be embarrassed
mr. Nadler is you for the way you've
addressed this body this is the United
States Senate you're not in charge here
that exchange drew a rare rebuke from
Chief Justice John Roberts I think it is
appropriate at this point for me to
admonish both the house managers and the
president's counsel in equal terms
I do think those addressing the Senate
should remember where they are the call
for civility came after 13 hours of
debate
Trump's complete and total obstruction
makes Richard Nixon look like a choirboy
the president has done absolutely
nothing wrong
Democrats say it is crucial to hear from
witnesses including former national
security adviser John Bolton we are
ready to present our case we are ready
to call our witnesses the question is
will you let us but the White House
Counsel says they had their chance they
asked you to do something that they
refused to do for themselves and then
accuse you of a cover-up when you don't
do it in the end the Senate's Republican
majority blocked all 11 Democratic
amendments to subpoena White House
officials and other agencies for
documents
the amendment is tabled and the rules
passed with two handwritten concessions
Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
made early on first that each side's
opening arguments would be spread over
three days instead of two and second the
houses evidence would be automatically
entered into the record still as
Democrats called for amendment after
amendment we got a preview of opening
arguments why are we here are we here
because of a phone call we are here sir
to follow the facts apply the law be
guided by the Constitution and present
the truth to the American people that is
why we are here mr. Sekulow and if you
don't know now you know each side will
have three days for 24 hours of debate
in the opening arguments that's a total
of six days then 16 hours of questions
from the Senators then another round of
votes on witnesses and documents and
that is when some Republicans might
cross sides and vote with the Democrats
Anthony all right chip thank you
you